[Aplausos]
[Música]
a
mexicanos a grito de guerra
así comienza nuestro himno nacional
bélico
así ha sucedido a través de la historia
independencia
guerras
para llegar a ello es necesario saber
con quien combatimos cuáles son nuestras
armas
y para ello hay que conocerlos a través
de la historia en esta imagen nos
muestra como el ser humano con su
creatividad
un palo
una piedra las fusiona para convertirlo
en una herramienta
una herramienta que va evolucionando
hasta convertirse en lo que vemos en la
otra diapositiva un arma de alto impacto
hacia sucedido en nuestra historia como
mexicanos hemos tenido
a nuestro guerrero nuestro dios de la
guerra
esa cultura se ha ido poco a poco
metiendo y se nos ha ido inculcando a
través de nuestro adn
podemos apreciar hoy en día
por medio de imágenes
por medio de frases
como estamos llegamos la violencia hoy
en día ya para nosotros es natural ver
los índices de violencia
quisiera compartir con ustedes esta
frase que me ha dejado huella
el cuerpo dispara
lo que el espíritu carga
históricamente cargamos
y detonamos
lo que nos han dejado nuestros ancestros
esa cultura que está tan permeada
me gustaría disparar y gatillar de esa
pregunta cuántas armas tienen en su casa
en la mía yo encontré 3
3 de juguete
ustedes cuantos tienen
tienen hijos
tienen videojuegos violentos
de una forma u otra
podemos apreciar
que esa violencia como comentó cada vez
es más real
esto es un arma de juguete
en cualquier momento puede ser disparado
avienta aire
si se carga con balines puede arrojar y
poder lastimar a alguien
estos juguetes se pueden encontrar en
centros departamentales
ese es el grado de violencia que a veces
llegamos en nuestras casas
quisiera compartir
con ustedes
cada uno de las batallas que llegamos a
tener
de manera consciente o inconsciente cada
uno de ustedes hoy en día se encuentra
en una batalla
puede ser una batalla personal
puede ser una batalla de pareja puede
ser una batalla familiar
puede ser una batalla social dependerá
de ustedes quiénes son
esas batallas se viven día con día
las seis batallas que he tenido a través
de mi trayectoria la primera fue el
saber reconocer
quien era como persona
dure varios años puesto que esa pregunta
me lo hicieron en primero de secundaria
quién eran no supo contestar hasta años
después elegí estoy convencido de lo que
soy soy artista
tengo estudios tengo licenciatura tengo
más días pero soy artista orgullosamente
tapatío
orgullosamente mexicano la segunda
batalla
mis padres
me dijeron que eligieran lo que quisiera
que pudiera ser barrendero pero el mejor
cuando les dije que iba a ser artista me
dijeron hazle como quieras no vas a ser
artista duró unos años para poder
asimilar eso hasta que un día dije cómo
puedo ganar esa batalla y la palabra que
utilicé fue la siguiente estoy dispuesto
a morir por ello
fue cuando mis padres me dijeron si así
lo quieres te respetamos la tercera fue
la comunidad artística al entrar al
gremio con una nueva propuesta o con una
propuesta que genera valor fue empezar a
explorar diferentes técnicas hasta
llegar a la huella dactilar
la huella es la que me ha definido y así
lo ha elegido para ser el artista que
deja huella de manera visible o de
manera invisible quiero dejar huella
y así fue como poco a poco me he
convertido el artista que deja huella
la siguiente fue el gobierno
de niño de s
tener solamente una escultura en la
calle solamente una pero que se pudiera
tocar que la pudieras admirar
ahora he puesto una galería en
guadalajara otra en zapopan otra en
morelia y otras esculturas más que han
estado regadas
siguiente batalla sedena
y va por unas cuantas armas
y me entregaron toneladas de armas
y la última por méxico me interesa que
en mexico se haga una potencia mundial
en arte
lo decretó y lucharé para que así sea
como pienso hacerlo impactos que dejan
huella
como ustedes pueden ver
traigo
algunas muestras de ello y la forma o la
historia en que comienza esto fue a
través de mi árbol genealógico sin darme
cuenta empecé a explorar por el patrón
de recurrencia y veo que cuando estudió
vio es codificación
existe del lado materno patrón de
recurrencia muerte
familiares tíos
hermano disparado
y es investigar más digo voy a elegir
transformar las armas en arte por mi
familia
me imagino algo como una colección
pequeña de unas cuantas armas hoy con la
sedena tengo algunas conversaciones
empiece a profundizar la charla
y me entregan más de 8 toneladas de
armas
esta es la primera escultura es un
águila
las alas extendidas es de 190 un poco
más de lo que tienen mis manos diez
centímetros más
la segunda la pueden apreciar en la
parte de afuera
todas estas armas
fueron dadas por los ciudadanos de
manera
voluntaria se llamó canje de armas 2017
que consistía en entregar las armas y se
entregaban lo que eran electrodomésticos
quienes las entregaban quienes estaban
sensibles a ellos eran abuelas eran
madres preocupadas por sus hijos
pueden reconocer en la parte de las
orejas
que son proyectiles en la parte de los
testículos
tiene lo que son granadas
eso es lo que tiene la ciudadanía
en sus casas
la siguiente
este es un arma
fueron cortadas después de haber sido
cortadas las entregan y la forma de
hacerlo se generan con micro alambre se
empiezan a unificar y generan ahorita
está escultura mide más de tres metros
de alto
y entremos
a este
movimiento
juguemos sin violencia
campaña con la sedena el cual le invitan
a formar parte de esto y dice no hay
álvaro tú que estás en el medio
podríamos trabajar en conjunto empezamos
a generar un equipo multidisciplinario
muchos de ellos están aquí empezamos a
crear
esta campaña
en dónde consistía en que los niños
entregaban sus juguetes bélicos en el
momento eran portados se les entregaba
un diploma un decálogo ese decálogo
consistían en estos diez esto es la
formación de valores cada uno de ellos
tiene un impacto que deja huella tiene
un sentido que si es cultivado llega a
ser transformado se esperaba recolectar
seis mil juguetes cuántos obtuvimos
veinte mil 75 juguetes bélicos
si quisiera ponerle un ejemplo
y se imagina
todos los asientos son mil y tantos 1200
estaremos hablando que sería
aproximadamente
19 veces de los asientos puestos en
armas aquí el arma más poderosa en el
mundo es el arte
el arte es el saber hacer
eso lo que dice timo lógicamente cada
uno de nosotros sabemos qué hacer cuando
lo sabemos hacer se convierte en un arte
se ha dicho el arte bélico el arte
culinario el arte de la arquitectura el
arte de las matemáticas el arte de la
construcción el arte de hablar
cada una de las cosas que ustedes hagan
háganlo con arte
ese arte cuando se ejercita se fortalece
una vez fortalecido se lleva una máxima
y una máxima
llega a generar
lo que es una explosión
y esa explosión consiste en el talento
yo les aseguro porque lo estudiado
que ustedes son el arma más poderoso que
existe
se los puedo asegurar se los puedo
confirmar con esto
su huella dactilar
no existe
en el pasado una huella como los de
ustedes no existe en el presente y no va
a existir en el futuro hay algo que
tienen ustedes que es único e
irrepetible
es por eso que el saber hacer y explotar
en el talento puede ser una muestra de
que méxico se convierta en potencia
mundial quién de ustedes les gustaría
explotar su talento
esas manos
me gustaría que se las llevaran al pecho
y que se preguntarán
cuál es su más profundo deseo si gustan
cerrar los ojos lo pueden hacer
si pueden escuchar su corazón
como bombea
y que se hagan conscientes
dejen de oírse para escucharse
ustedes son su más profundo deseo como
es su deseo es su intención como es su
intención es su voluntad como es su
voluntad son sus actos y como son sus
actos va a ser su destino quieren dejar
una huella personal
quieren dejar una huella familiar
quieren dejar una huella social
una huella nacional o una huella mundial
los invito
a que dejen huella
porque viva méxico
mágico
[Aplausos]